[Applaudissements]
c'est un féminicide qui ébranle tout un
paystin l' suc paeomicidio Julia Cres
Dino voici l'histoire de juliatine 22
ans tu par
son
VI
Julie éit une fille de sa génération son
image sourante a tellement eu d'ff sur
les gens et tout le monde a commencé à
parler
d'elle bonjour à tous cette semaine je
vous parle d'une histoire qui bouscule
la société italienne Julia 22 ans a été
tuée de 26 coups de couteau par son
petit ami Philippo 22 ans lui aussi elle
est la 105 victime de féminicide cette
année en Italie plutôt que de lui
accorder une minute de silence des
milliers de personnes ont préféré lui
rendre homage en faisant du bruit pour
exprimer leur
colère nous sommes dans la soirée du 11
novembre à quelques dizaine de
kilomètres de Venise Julia chetine est
raccompagné chez elle par son exptit ami
Philippo toureta à 23h1 la voiture du
jeune homme stationne sur un parking à
proximité du domicile de la jeune fille
il y a un voisin qui a entendu Julia
crier tu me fais mal la police
retrouvera plusieurs traces de sang
appartenant à Julia le voisin a appelé
la police pour appeler de l'aide qui
n'est jamais arrivé une vingtaine de
minutes plus tard la voiture de Philippo
est identifié sur des vidéos de
surveillance à quelques kilomètres de là
Dula s'échappe de la voiture avant
d'être rattrapé par Philippo qui lui
assène de nombreux coups de couteau la
jeune femme s'écroule
inerte
Filippo charge le corps dans sa voiture
avant de prendre la fuite la police
retrouvera à cet endroit des traces de
sang l'a
faamente
contci t n TR il momento
diuliatin Filippo turetta le
ricer
N sont ensemble se trouve ensemble
ailleurs cette hypothèse n'a pas duré
longtemps parce que tout de suite après
on a commencé à parler autour de la
famille de des violences psychologiques
dont julia était
victime Julia et Philippo ont 20 ans
lorsqu'il se rencontre sur les bancs de
l'université où il poursuivent tous les
deux des études d'ingénieur julie était
une fille de sa génération elle était
étudiante elle aimait bien passer du
temps avec sa famille et passerit du
temps dans la nature son image souriante
a tellement eu desffits sur les médias
sur les gens et tout le monde a commencé
à parler d'elle de sa
disparitionateate non non Ries a zoom il
Pandino non si
vede Pandino cétait quelqu'un qui
représente un peu l'image ser d'un
Italien
aujourd'hui Filippo par contre a été
décrit comme quelqu'un de moins ouvert
de moins sociable de plus timide
certainement quelqu'un qui retrouvait
son souris que à côté de Julia quelques
mois avant sa disparition Julia décide
de quitter
Filippo anche ieri mi ha scritto una
cosa del
tipo io sarò sempre qua ad aspettarti e
e l'unica cosa che mi che mi farebbe
felicissimo e che migliore la mia vita
SBE tu mi Dessi una seconda possibilità
minchi
genere sont mis ensemble à nouveau et
après
é
définitivement
ACC
confr à se voir parce que Julia RAC à
ses amis
elle était préoccupé
mi viene del tipo super depresso Hao di
manginate a sfitto che pensa solo ad
ammazzarsi vorrebbe morire che vorrebbe
uccidersi che non trova più un senso per
andare
avanti vorrei fortemente sparire Dall
sua vita ma non come far
per peré mi so INPA perché ho Troppa
paura
che possa farsi male in qualche modo non
credo che lo
farebbe perché mi sembra che mi dica
queste cose più per costringermi a
stargli sempre appiccicato però il
rischio c'è nella mia testa soprattutto
e il fatto che potrebbe essere colpa Mia
mi uccide come cosa e non come
comparmi cont temp du fait que Julia une
fois diplômé partir ailleurs pour
continuer ses études ou travailler le
fait qu'elle devienne totalement
indépendante et qu'elle disparaisse
aussi alors qu'un avis de disparition
est émis par les autorités italiennes la
voiture de Filippo est identifié sur des
vidéosurveillance en direction du nord
de l'Italie une semaine après sa
disparition le corps de Julia est
finalement retrouvé dans un canal à 130
km de chez
elle non Provo né odio né rabbia non
Provo
nulla io penso solo alla mia Giulia che
ormai non c'è più l'autopsie révélera
que Julia est morte d'un choc
hémorragique après avoir reçu 26 coups
de
couteau le vittime di femminicidio e
l'ultima è Giulia cecchettini ha
spezzato anche la Vita Mia eella mia
famiglia perché io mi sveglio ogni
mattina e mi viene da piangere a pensare
che Mia sorella non è nella camera a
fianco alla mia
le lendemain de la découverte du corps
de Julia Filippo est interpellé en
Allemagne à proximité de Leipzig Filippo
turetta stato arrestato dopo 7orni di
fuga era in auto sen benzina
laceem t de sang sur ses chaussures les
sièges de sa voiture ainsi qu'un couteau
la première chose qu'il a dit on FO
arrêté par la police allemande c'est
j'ai tué mon exptit ami je me corrige il
a dit j'ai tué
mon Filippo déare au policier navoir pas
trouvé le courage de mettre fin à s
jour minuto sileno Jul nonario bis
prenderea cosa un esempio e trasformar
in potere per trasformare qu sà la vita
di altre nel futuroé star qua le mani in
mano a piangere non serve null dobbiamo
protegere le ragazze del futuro e le Raz
presente che son con oggié giia questo
av
vol la nostra comunis
alleeerva un minuto di silenzi in Rico
di Giulia cecchettin la
studentessaenne uccisa dal suo ex
fidanzato e di tutte le donne vittime di
femminici notre société je dirais que
c'est plutôt l'âge de Philippo le fait
que quelqu'un de son âge
tue son ex petit amis ça nous choque ça
nous choque parce que dansun certains
côtés ça nous montre que ce qu'on est en
train de faire pour combattre certains
préjuger au sein de la société italienne
envers les femmes n'est pas suffisant
plutôt qu'une minute de silence des
milliers d'étudiants ont préféré
observver une minute de bruit pour
exprimer leur
colère
[Musique]
non è con un minuto di silenzio che si
effettua veramente il cambiamento che
migliori la situazione qui per un Flash
Mob per Giulia per dare Forza alla
sorella Elena che ha deciso di chiamare
questo omicidio con il suo reale nome
femminicidio omicidio di Stato omicidio
di
potere
alors qu'une minute de bruit est
observée à la Chambre des députés une
loi contre les violences faites aux
femmes est voté au Sénat à l'unanimité
celle-ci renforce les mesures
d'éloignement des conjoints violents et
étend l'utilisation du bracelet
électronique rappelons-nous que dans le
44 % de cas une femme tuée par son
ex-conjoint son conjoint son mari femme
victime de féminicide avait alerté la
police avant d'être touée il n'a pas été
assez
[Musique]
protégé le 25 novembre cette année était
très important pour l'Italie pour se
battre pas seulement contre la violence
envers les femmes dans notre pays mais
en général contre une vision des femmes
au sein de notre société qui n'a pas
encore changé pas
[Musique]
assez
l'citia
CR j'espère qu'il y a avant et apr je le
sens que c'était un mouvement tellement
partagé cette fois je l'avais jamais vu
dans are pays avant il y a la
possibilité que cette tragédie nous
amène vers une meilleure solution d'un
problème qui est énorme au sein de notre
société depuis la mort de Julia de
nouvelles femmes ont été tué en Italie
ce qui porte le nombre de victimes à 107
depuis le début de l'année en France on
compte déjà 121 féminicides en 2023 donc
en terme de proportion c'est quasi
similaire merci à tous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que vous en
avez pensé en commentaire et à vous
abonner à la chaîne j'en profite pour
remercier toutes les équipes de brut qui
font un travail incroyable pour qu'on
puisse vous proposer ce genre de vidéo
et sur ce je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle grande
histoire